[Music]
welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is gonna be my new Avatar The Last
Airbender Netflix video Bryan Konietzko
was doing a bunch of updates about the
series and why things are taking so long
so we'll break it all down is a bunch of
big stuff happening behind the scenes he
did tease some really cool stuff coming
up so if you're new to the channel be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos
I'll think of some fun Avatar The Last
Airbender a themed giveaway to do when
they start actually rolling in two
episodes but I'll just break this down
top seven style starting with number
seven the Avatar The Last Airbender
Netflix series has been delayed way past
the original intended release date of
2020 for a couple reasons
as you would probably assume but it's
not just because of Hollywood having to
shut down for a couple weeks if you
don't live in the United States recently
Los Angeles and a couple other major
cities like New York and San Francisco
went effectively on lockdown making
everybody just stay inside their homes
for the next couple of weeks so pretty
much all of Hollywood all movies all TV
shows that were in production like
Avatar The Last Airbender were forced to
take a mandatory two-week break at least
it could be longer than that but because
everyone's been trapped in their homes
for the past week or so Brian can yetsko
has been posting more frequently and
finally started talking about avatar the
last airbender Netflix episodes this is
what he said so I'll just paste his
messages here hello friends tense times
indeed I encourage you to take the time
to read the following and heed his
advice as much as you can
he posted a bunch of scientific articles
and newspaper clippings of stuff that's
going on with the virus I'm not gonna
put that stuff in the video that's not
really relevant to what's going on with
Avatar The Last Airbender
but then he thanked everyone just said
take care stay safe then apologize for
the lack of official updates from
Netflix from himself Michael DiMartino
on the Avatar The Last Airbender series
he said it's been a slow process way
slower than they ever expected I'll
explain what that means in a second and
what he means when he says very exciting
things are in the works on the project
obviously that's what you want to hear
that there's really cool stuff coming up
soon then he just reminded everyone to
take it easy because it's going to be a
rough couple of months and they'll share
more updates on Avatar The Last
Airbender as soon as Netflix will let
them
Netflix actually controls the flow of
information so if you don't hear updates
from creators on series like stranger
things for instance is because Netflix
doesn't want them releasing information
so number six what does Brian mean when
he says development on the series went
way slower than he or Mike ever thought
it would well the good news actually in
that is that the big holdup wasn't so
much about the story or the scripts if
you weren't sure about what the story's
going to be all they're doing is
adapting the story of the original
animated Avatar The Last Airbender
series but doing it as a live-action
series but because the original animated
episodes were only around 21 to 23
minutes long the new episodes will be
closer to 40 to 45 minutes maybe even
longer anime is famous for its filler
just Eston arruda one piece Dragon Ball
or any long-running popular anime series
so if you think about the original
Avatar The Last Airbender series as
being the manga that they're using to
create the new hour-long series just
imagine that they have to write
themselves a bunch of extra filler to
stretch those episodes out more dialogue
more character work between all the big
bending scenes the fight scenes just to
fill that time they wrote and supervised
all the old episodes so it'd be kind of
like Toriyama coming back to rewrite his
old Dragon Ball manga and adding a bunch
of extra material with each issue so
it's good filler it's not bad filler
there are a ton of high-level costume
design and set design people in
Hollywood available to them so actually
building the look of the series and the
costumes isn't that hard and because
they have Sifu ki-suh there's also gonna
be working with them on all the bending
stuff they already did all the hard work
when they were developing the first
series like if you've watched any of the
behind the scenes from the original
series you can see him developing the
bending styles it'll be the same for the
new live-action series so it'll look
really badass
they'll probably wind up doing eight
episodes per season and hopefully they
make it to five to six seasons hopefully
Netflix doesn't make them condense some
of that story down into fewer seasons
but break down would be kind of like
this they end their season one with the
Winter Solstice Anne gets the message
from Roku about having to master all the
four elements and defeat Fire Lord Ozai
before sozen's comet arrives and they're
all dead meat they end season two with
the original book one finale the siege
of the north
my girlfriend turned into the moon
that's rough buddy they in season three
with the library where they may
wan-chi tong in Appa gets kidnapped then
they in season four with the original
season three finale crossroads of
Destiny where Aang almost gets killed by
Azula and goes into a coma that they end
season five with the day of the Black
Sun probably the most memorable event
from that episode is Zuko finally
confronting his father Fire Lord Ozai in
Ozai basically telling him that he never
loved him
Zuko finally stands up to him in vows to
stop him no matter what then obviously
you end the final season with the
original series finale
sozin's comet that was a three-part
episode so hopefully they don't try to
mash that all into one single hour but
number five the real holdup on the
development of the series is all the
technical stuff there are a lot of
things that go into that first and
foremost is the actual bending scenes
and fight scenes the main characters
anka tarah Sokka Zuko eventually Toph
when she comes along in season two are
all between the ages of 11 and 16 even
if you cast actors in their 20s that can
pass as teenagers it is super hard to
find young actors that are that size who
can one look a little bit like the
characters at least two aren't total
actors and three can perform at
least some of the bending and fight
choreography like it's super easy to
find good actors who can also fight on
camera but there aren't a ton of kids
that you can pick from that can do all
those things really good example are the
kids from stranger things they do a
decent job with all the acting and the
character scenes but the kids themselves
do very little actual fighting
and when xi is performing fight scenes
using her powers to fight someone like
the demagogue and she usually just
scrunches her face her nose will bleed
she's screams sometimes and that's way
easier to perform for a kid actor than a
full-blown graceful martial arts fight
in number four right now the really cool
thing that everyone in Hollywood is just
starting to do for really high caliber
TV series like Avatar The Last Airbender
is supposed to be is using the filming
technology that they developed for Star
Wars the Mandalorian I did a separate
video about this a little while ago they
released a trailer and it basically
shows how they filmed the Mandalorian
episodes in a very holodeck kind of way
if you're talking about Star Trek Easter
eggs they have a brand new camera system
in a giant video wall that envelops
their soundstage so that when they're
with an actor they can project the
environment around the actor and it's
synched with the actors movements so
that when the actor will turn their head
the environment will rotate around so
it's like you're filming on a holodeck
that's the kind of technology that they
need on a show like Avatar The Last
Airbender where everything looks amazing
all the locations all the buildings the
palaces it's really hard to find places
like that in real life to film where you
can actually take all the actors and get
everything done number three when are
they gonna announce the main cast so
originally they were supposed to start
shooting in February this year for an
expected release date of the end of 2020
so they probably already have at least
some of their cast lockdown but because
production has ground to a halt all over
Hollywood they'll probably take their
time in finding the rest of the main
cast nobody in Hollywood will be able to
film anything for at least a couple more
weeks possibly longer than that
typically Netflix won't let people
reveal their cast until right before
they start filming with the actors and
right now it seems like that won't be
till at least the summer at the earliest
if all the craziness dies down
there were some casting rumors and leaks
a little while ago I did a few videos
about that but the biggest announcement
they've made so far in terms of cast is
that Dante Basco
will be in the new series they even did
a big panel with Dante Basco recently
for the 15th anniversary of the original
series it's been 15 years I did a video
for that so I'll link it at the end of
this but he talked about some funny
stuff his memories from the series they
also rag Dal ittle bit on the Great
Divide so if there's any material that
they don't adapt from the original
series for the new episodes it's
probably gonna be the Great Divide
episode they wouldn't say what role
Dante Bosco was gonna play in the new
series so I'm hoping it's either gonna
be uncle Iroh Fire Lord Ozai or even
cabbage man rise of cabbage man number
two also really important Jeremy
Zuckerman will be coming back to do the
music if you didn't watch the original
series or you didn't know he is the
person who did all the music for avatar
the last airbender then he came back and
did the music for legend of korra he did
an interview last year where he said
he'd be rearranging his original avatar
music for the new episodes so if you
really love the music from the original
avatar series the apply start releasing
tracks like that separately from the
series like when toss a coin to your
witcher blew up after The Witcher
Netflix series started
number one WTF big question now when our
episodes going to be released before the
big virus hit and delayed everything
even more I was expecting them to
release episodes by next spring it takes
between six months in a year to finish
special effects on episodes so with this
shutdown the past week now we'll
probably be lucky to get new avatar the
last airbender episodes by the end of
next year just plan for the end of next
year and if they somehow energy bend
themselves into an early release date in
the fall we can all just celebrate the
surprise so if you have any big
questions about what's going on with
Avatar The Last Airbender or you want
any special bonus videos for the series
just let me know in the comments I will
do more update videos as they bring more
news like Bryan said they're getting
ready to announce some more really big
really cool stuff everyone click here
for all my new avatar the last airbender
videos and click here to learn about
ahsoka tano coming to the live-action
Mandalorian a season 2 thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome
we'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you